[Music]
welcome to the YouTube channel
the vintage egyptologists I'm Colleen
Darnell I'm John Darnielle this is
Narmer and over there is Kenny so we
were thinking what would be the perfect
first video for youtube and of course
YouTube is the home of funny cat videos
so what better Egypt illogical question
to ask then did the ancient Egyptians
have an equivalent to funny cat videos
we shall see
the ancient Egyptians interactive with
animals in all sorts of ways they had
pet cats and pet dogs especially for
Sanji's but they also could worship
animals it's important to remember
though that when you see an ancient
Egyptian worshipping a cat called the
beautiful cat for example in some
Steeley from a site called Terra Medina
that they're not worshipping a cat as
such they're worshipping the God that is
represented by that animal by the cat
and we know that the cat could be a
sacred animal of the Sun God so whether
they had pets in the homes or they were
worshipping something like the jackal as
Anubis or a cat as bostedt or a goose as
the God a moon that the Egyptians
recognized the significance of animals
in their world one of the places we see
the ancient Egyptians worshipping gods
in animal form playing with animals as
pets and also depicting animals acting
in rather humorous ways even
representing people is the city of Deir
el-medina that's the modern name for the
Royal workmen's village on the west bank
of ancient Thebes modern Luxor during
the New Kingdom so we look at a plan of
the West Bank here of ancient Thebes to
see Darryl Medina is a little bit behind
of the great mortuary temple of ramesses
the third at Madinat habu also river
north a little bit of the valley of the
queens so just to orient ourselves a
little bit here's the wadi ain the road
into the valley of the kings and these
bodies here are the valley of the kings
queen hatshepsut our king hatshepsut who
excavated the first tomb here in the
valley
got the prime spot just behind the bay
here in which she built her great
mortuary temple at deriv re so if we
move south through these various bays
getting close to what's often called the
valley of the queens actually we might
better call it the necropolis of the
royal dependents just before we get
there nestled behind a little hill
hidden more or less from the cultivation
is deir el-medina the city of the royal
workmen of the new kingdom the first
evidence we have for any sort of
construction there seem to be some
stamped bricks of Tut most the first
third ruler of the 18th dynasty but as
far as those royal workmen and their
families were concerned their patron
saints were the second king of the 18th
dynasty and his mother almost Nefertari
their worshipped in a number of places
on steely and in depictions and private
tombs here we are in the tomb of nebamun
and pookie on the west bank of thebes
and we see depictions of Amenhotep the
first and his mother Olmos Nefertari
wife of King Olmos first ruler of the
18th dynasty these were the patron
saints of the Royal workmen on the west
bank of ancient Thebes and those workmen
had cats and other animals with whom
they played they depicted some of their
gods in animal form and occasionally
they show animals doing humorous things
animals acting like both gods and people
so that artists community at Roma Deena
is spectacular I mean you had people
that are literate for the most part that
are well trained artistically and
have everything from the books they were
reading the scrolls they were reading
like literature or instructions
religious texts even a dream
interpretation manual and then to have
their little drawings of animals is
really really fantastic so I was going
to talk about this one where we have
it's a ostracon so a flake of limestone
that's been painted and we see a mouse
wearing a very long pleated linen kilt
so this would be a male mouse based on
the depiction and he's drinking wine
from a really long straw we actually
have some surviving elements of these
straws they would have little balls that
would have worked as a sieve at the
bottom so that you didn't suck up any of
the dregs from the wine jar but this was
apparently used in a festival sitting
when you don't want to have to wait for
someone to come around and replenish
your cup when you're supposed to consume
a lot of one sitting you just drink it
straight out of the wine amphora
we'll talk about this later this would
be for a festival such as the festival
of drunkenness tacky as it's called um
but the the interesting thing here is
that we have depictions of people doing
the very same thing so there's a there's
a fairly well-known little Stila from
western easy attic soldiers of off.not
and drinking out of the amphora like
this and the attendant who's taking care
of the emperor here is a cat I believe
it is you mean you see the
reconstruction with the little ears and
then there's another cat fixing the
mailmouse's wig so we have a cat a genus
hairdresser we have a cat attending to
make sure there's enough wine for this
mouse to drink and there seems to be a
baby cat or no cat is a person down here
and opposite the cat that is drawn as a
cat not as a anthropomorphised cat
opposite that cat behind the chair of
the
mouse who's drinking its what looks like
a duck or a goose and this is
interesting because we have at least one
really interesting depiction of a cat
hugging literally with his arm around
the neck of a goose or a pet cat hugging
a pet goose while a pet monkey jumps
over the - from a slightly earlier
Theban tune so before we show you that
though I want to get one other fun cat
and mouse image in here this is from a
papyrus in the Turin museum known as the
erotic papyrus for reasons that we won't
get into at the moment we'll talk about
these later love poetry but here we have
a mouse eating chariot the chariot is
pulled by dogs and then the fortress
that the mouse is attacking is manned by
cats so this is Tom and Jerry ancient
Egyptian style and they've taken a
military depiction what normally would
have people and horses
the CGI a fortress manned by yet more
people they've now transformed into a
battle between cats and mice so at least
one Egyptologist and a number of people
have thought possibly this is true
thought that some of these might
represent let's say animal stories
fables like Aesop's fables one thing
that's true in all of these so some of
the outlandish depictions I think
there's one where there's a bird
climbing a ladder to get at a
hippopotamus who's in a tree okay right
behind the it's right behind the cat
fortress being attacked by the mice and
dog chariot these images of animals
doing human-like things and animals
doing things with other animals with
whom they wouldn't necessarily be doing
those things even if they were entered
for morpha sighs um these scenes are
associated on the papyrus with a rather
wild sort of orgiastic interaction
between apparently a priest a priest
these things are all apparently
associated with the idea of
the new years for the Egyptian this idea
of the change of the old to the new year
everything is in the balance we have the
possibility of a new better time but
then things might also not go the way
you want so it's a time of the return of
the goddess of the eye of the Sun rising
and the inundation waters and you need
to make sure everything works and so
this this topsy-turvy world the world
turned upside down is something that
both cycles on this papyrus the human
erotic section and the animal fable
quoting quote section what what they all
share in common and speaking of those
animal fables and meaning behind the
aged Egyptian equivalent of a funny cat
video we have this scene from the tomb
of Anand which has exactly what you were
describing earlier we have a seated cat
right next to a goose the goose is neck
is actually overlapping the cat and the
cat is hugging the goose and so is this
in ancient Egyptian funny cat video or
are we looking at something now this is
beneath a depiction of the throne of
queen Tiye the wife of I'm going to tap
the third so it's beneath the Queen's
throne in the tomb of audit and that's
an important bit of information I one
thing I see here too without talking
with this leader that has a parallel for
some of the things and nagahama Bob
early dynastic tableau so once again
proving that the pre-dynastic and the
protodynastic period set the stage for
everything that we see that comes later
that we turn Veronica joke so if we look
at the cat hugging the goose what could
this possibly mean is it simply animals
behaving against their nature almost
certainly not the chief sacred animals
of the God on moon were the RAM and the
goose his consort as the goddess moved
and the goddess moot has both the
vulture and the
as her sacred animals so when a moon the
goose is being hugged by the cat who is
moot you're actually seeing a depiction
of the union of God and Goddess and one
of the times this occurs this union of
the God and the goddess is the time of
the New Year's because the goddess is
the cat evokes the goddess of the eye of
the son who's the lioness and the far
south in the winter when she's angry and
she comes back to Egypt at the time of
the New Year the longest day the rising
of the inundation waters and she needs
to be placated so that she goes from
being angry Sauk Matt who wants to eat
you and drink your blood to being nice
happy bostedt the cat who is helpful
it's what we should really look at is
the monkey the monkey introduces a topic
we'll talk about later which is the
ancient Egyptian love poetry so Jon's
just gone off to get a copy of an
ancient Egyptian love poem we have a
number of these preserved in papyri and
on ostraca from around 1250 BCE so about
the reign of Ramses the second and
there's one love poem in particular that
john is translated that relates to this
whole question of the leaping Mogi over
the cat hugging the goose so here is the
love poem we're discussing rather short
the man in question is outside the
towered House of the beloved some sort
of elaborate country villa
apparently more is in the middle and he
comes and he finds that the door is open
and the monkey is about to escape oh and
I see the hurry to get out
Galu there for monkey right that's the
monkey the monkey is about to get out
and it says that the beloved is going
ape she's going Kennedy the word
literally to be like a baboon it's like
a baboon self
she's really upset just like the English
idiom um and he then concludes by saying
he wishes that he were the doorkeeper so
that she would be angry with him that's
great so the monkey here in the love
poem represents the god Thoth right the
monkey here then apparently would
represent the god Thoth since the woman
is really angry they appear to be
likening her to the goddess of the eye
of the Sun this sort of imagery appears
in some of the other love hands the
setting is generally a festival setting
probably weren't associated with the
goddess anyway so the goddess Hathor who
in one of the myths can go south into
Nubia and she has to be brought back by
the god of Thoth who can be represented
as a monkey so that it's as if he's no
longer pacifying the goddess he's no
longer bringing her back instead the
monkey has escaped and that's why the
woman is so angry that seems to be so
she's going ape she's raging and the
monkey that probably symbolically
represents the god Thoth who represents
writing and learning and the use of
knowledge and ritual to come to goddess
he's just given up he's thrown in the
towel running away she's enraged but the
man is so in love with her that he
wishes that he was the doorkeeper so at
least she'd be angry at it so I think
we've solved the mystery of the monkey
that the monkey relates to the goddess
Hathor and is beneath the throne of Tia
probably because she's also being linked
in to the goddess right so and of course
one thing to remember here always is
even though there's religious imagery in
the love poetry these are still love
poems even though there is imagery to
the interaction of the animals beneath
the throne there's no reason to believe
that Tia did not actually have a pet
goose a pet cat and pet monkey and maybe
several of all of these so like all
things for the ancient Egyptians they're
not just scenes of daily life nor are
they simply loaded with ritual and
religious imagery but each increases the
me
of the other so these are very pithy
images and texts with multiple images
and levels of imagery overlaid so next
we have to look at the goose oh now this
reminds me of the image of almond as the
goose that we find in that prayer of the
priest pahu so a priest named PHA who
probably from about the reign of
Amenhotep ii carved this rock
inscription out in the desert northwest
of ancient Thebes modern Luxor and what
he says is I cried out to Amon when I
was in the midst of the river in the
depth of the river and the waves were
high and he caused that I go upon the
earth by my own two feet or on my own
volition then it says when he actually
cried out to Amon it says to cry - Amon
which the Wahb priests Paulo son of nye
made the cry - Amon it's so great to see
PHA whose prayer Domon so here we have I
am shipwrecked
there's the I am shipwrecked the Baga
cuckoo and the he caused that I cry out
cry out or give voice like so this is
the preposition me for like and then PHA
which is a bird with its wings so that's
the definite article the the Semin which
is oops
so the Semin goose here almost certainly
represents the God a moon and the fact
that our moon causes that the rescued
PHA who cry out don't certainly an
allusion to the cry of the goose of
almond itself as a creator this cry of
creation and that actually reminds me of
a little industry
accompanying the OPEC scenes in Luxor
Temple oh let's look at those next Amin
as the creator is this great boost this
cackling goose if we go to Luxor Temple
which we can't do right this very minute
but we can go to Luxor Temple in this
copy of the OPEC procession scenes made
during the reign of two dogs almond and
completed under Sethi the first in the
great Cullen odd Hall of Omnitech the
third at Luxor we see that the the great
portable bark of the god Amun that the
big Rams head here is resting inside
luxor temple with the barks of moot the
goddess moot and the child god Khonsu
and the barks are about to leave the
temple here the king is going out in
front the barks are now being carried
out and one of the priests sort of at
the head of the procession here down
here near these little booths for the
food for the banquets that would
accompany this one of the priests is
turning his back here and he's saying
something to the bark he says is beg ah
we Zemin beg egg bengaii Zemin beg egg
how weary is the cackling goose how
weary is the cackling goose the goose of
Amun as creator so it's a great
expression because it alludes to almond
as the creator creation in Egyptian
religious texts often involves a loud
sound and a watery expanse like it in
another world books in the fifth hour
yes so so a divine epiphany is often
accompanied by this loud sound water
crashing booming sound the cackle of the
goose then evokes this water avoid the
emergence of the created world out of
noon out of this watery oneness and the
ability of the Creator God to sail out
on the receding waters like the goose
and of course the cackle
it's also the weariness the tired aspect
of the Creator God after the exertions
of creation I think we can confidently
answer the question did the Egyptians
have an equivalent of a funny cat video
with a resounding yes probably with
ritual religious connotations so in
future videos we will talk more about
the loved poetry inch Egyptian festivals
ancient Egyptian religion and probably
yet more humorous ostraca and basijis of
course percent ease
[Music]